we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
this is so funny guys you know how i
sometimes tell you
there's a contingent of the left
i use the term revolutionary leftist or
stalinist leninist leftists some of you
prefer more pejorative terms like tanki
i just i don't i don't it's not a term
that i use
and
i pointed out last week something that
to most of you is now uncontroversial
there are leftists who play coy with
and defend and sometimes straight up
support in the case of maduro in
venezuela
these
revolutionary
authoritarian type figures that claim to
be left but are really
failures of leftism anyway a caller
really didn't like that he says it
doesn't exist he's furious with me take
a listen to this
did i just hear you correctly say that
some people on the left
are in favor of totalitarian regimes
they won't call them totalitarian
regimes but in the interest of claiming
to be
for socialism or against american
imperialism
they will end up supporting those very
things for real david yeah
no that's wrong you're 110 wrong that
makes no sense at all what
some people on the left like me
are against
fighting with russia because we don't
like our materialistic attitude that's a
different issue and as i've said
i literally addressed this
you can't just say
i'm against american imperialism so we
want to just say whatever putin is doing
is fine
you can condemn something putin does
while saying i don't want the u.s
involved for example you can condemn
the insanity of the chavez maduro
regimes in venezuela while saying i
don't want the u.s picking a leader i
don't want the u.s pushing regime change
you
it i don't these folks get so triggered
by this u.s imperialistic attitude that
part that you said was correct
but not some people on the left are in
favor of totalitarian regimes that makes
no [ __ ] sense
again they would deny that they are
authorized and i by the way i did the
other thing is i didn't say totalitarian
i said authoritarian so it's like
this is this is the perfect example of
someone denying reality
and misstating my position but you know
it's i'm used to it by now
they're not they're not leftist if they
are they're people on the right only
writers
that's actually a really good point i
believe that a lot of these so-called
leftists who say
putin's not bad and bashar al-assad's
not bad and maduro's not bad and castro
was fine
i i that's my position is they're not
really on the left
they insist that they are but i would
actually agree inadvertently with the
caller i don't think those folks are
actually leftists anyway
that's a perfect example of what i've
been telling you guys about we've got a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about the believed front-runners
for joe biden's supreme court pick we're
going to talk about the hilarity that
has developed with glenn younkin's tip
line to snitch on teachers it's actually
hilarious and we will talk about
problems with the child tax credit
problems with the child tax credit in
terms of it
actually being distributed to people
we're going to talk about confusion
around that and much more on today's
bonus show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com to get instant access
we will see you then or on tomorrow's
show